so we take a look outside boy it looks
hot already doesn't it well temperatures
are pretty darn warm even at this early
hour this is usually when we get our
coolest temps of the day
here they are lots of 80s out there from
top to bottom
nellis back down to 80 degrees the
coolest spot but man we've got a lot of
mid to upper 80s as well kyle canyon's
at 72 red rock
at 80 degrees so we hit 114 yesterday
very close to the record for yesterday
today we expect to exceed the record
high
and set a new one 115 today yesterday we
had a lot of clouds today
i think we'll have some clouds but not
quite as many 99 is the average high
there are heat warnings and watches and
advisories all over the
southwest and west and we are looking at
tropical development down here in the
gulf of mexico
that's another weather story we'll have
to follow the places that have been
getting
so much rain continue to get the rain
the places that are suffering through
extreme drought conditions and
exceptional drought
continue to stay dry and extremely hot
that's us that's us here in the desert
southwest now it is the
the monsoon awareness week as we head
towards the beginning of monsoon season
in july and this is a very typical
monsoon pattern high pressure over the
four corners
and moisture moving up from mexico and
it could be that we'll see
some thunderstorms in our local
mountains by tomorrow and friday we're
going to watch out for that but right
now we've got to get through this long
duration
intense heat wave excessive heat
warnings for the lower elevations
and heat advisories for our mountains
both continue until saturday night at
nine o'clock
115 not much in the way of wind 114
tomorrow friday and saturday more clouds
around thursday and friday
with that little bit of trapped moisture
that could bring thunderstorms and dry
lightning
summer officially starts sunday night
father's day
and our first full day of summer we see
just a little break in the heat or even
down below 105
later next week thank goodness